le débat sur le niqab a eu comme
conséquence de mettre presque
complètement de côté les questions qui
concernent les femmes et les enjeux liés
à l'égalité hommes femmes à travers le
regard de trois candidates alexandre h à
ce qu'a pu constater que les femmes ont
fait peu de progrès dans la société
canadienne
au cours des dernières années voyant son
reportage bonjour vous allez bien
michèle audette a l'habitude ex
présidente de l'association des femmes
autochtones du canada ex sous ministre
chargé de la condition féminine à québec
cette mère de cinq enfants s'occupent
des droits des femmes
pratiquement depuis toujours ce qui
m'anime en politique
jamais elle n'aurait cru devoir défendre
le droit des femmes à porter le niqab
priorité pour vous ça serait quoi
c'est l'égalité au surtout pour la femme
arabe est plutôt musulmans aujourd'hui
candidate libérale dans le comté de
terrebonne c'est pourtant ce qu'elle est
obligée de faire quotidiennement au
québec on aime les femmes
on n'a pas besoin d'un parti adoptent
une stratégie très vraiment que calculé
par monsieur harper par les
conservateurs de vraiment nous faire
peur comme citoyens citoyennes de nous
diviser groupe qu'on croque culture
compte culture alors que dans la vraie
vie au canada il ya très peu de femmes
qui portent le niqab
et pendant qu'on parle du niqab
ajoute-t-elle on ne parle pas des vrais
problèmes qui touchent les femmes en
commençant par les femmes autochtones
assassinées et disparues depuis 20 ans
il refuse de faire une enquête nationale
publique sur les 3000 femmes qui
manquent à l'appel ou qui ont été tués
mais va faire une enquête sur la
question du saumon à colombes du tanet
ou où est allé un bateau il ya 100 ans
de 10 ans dans l'arctique comme vous
pouvez le constater beaucoup beaucoup de
femmes puis comme vous voyez
prédominance berckoise djaouida sellah
et député npd est candidate dans le
comté de montarville sur la rive sud de
montréal
je suis jusque là en blanc en train de
clôturer le show félin la fameuse vague
orange de 2011 était en fait une vague
rose
les femmes représentaient 40% des élus
du jamais vu
l'équité entre femmes et hommes est une
de nos priorités
d'ailleurs nous avons l'intention
d'augmenter encore ce nombre là dans le
sens où maintenant nous avons comme 43%
de candidate femme algérienne d'origine
médecin de formation est mère de deux
enfants louis d'asselah a bien raison de
souligner l'exploit que son parti a
accompli en faisant élire 38 femmes à la
chambre des communes
la proportion des femmes a ainsi fait un
bond de 2,6 pour cent en une seule
élection passant à presque 25 pour ça
j'en rêvais remercie les joueurs mais
aussi j'aime bien vos les jeunes hommes
comme vous mais le canada reste loin
derrière au 50e rang des parlements du
monde
on doit parler des enjeux qui concernent
la femme dans sa globalité
au lieu de se concentrer sur deux femmes
à travers tout le canada qui ont refusé
de relever leur niqab pauvreté des aînés
majoritairement les femmes égalité
salariale garderie voilà autant d'enjeux
que djaouida sellah tente de mettre de
l'avant quand elle ne se fait pas
interpellé au sujet du niqab mais la
présence des femmes en politique lui
tiennent particulièrement à coeur
pas étonnant elle est passée par une
bonne école celle de l'association
femmes politique et démocratie depuis
owni a formé près de 900 femmes qui
voulaient se lancer en politique
trois ont été élus au fédéral sous la
bannière npd je me suis permis un petit
calcul rapide des cinq dernières
élections et le taux d'augmentation des
femmes d'une élection à l'autre et de -2
1% ce qui veut dire que pour atteindre
la parité ça prendrait encore 108 ans
d'autant plus que la plupart des partis
ne font pas de réels efforts dans ce
sens excepté le npd et le parti vert en
le parti conservateur n'avait que 22 %
de députées féminine le npd deux fois
plus en 2015 le npd est encore premier
dans la proportion de candidates qui
s'approche de la parité alors que moins
de 20% des candidats conservateurs sont
des femmes mais le groupe femmes
politique et démocratie ne pourra plus
contribué à lancer plus de femmes en
politique fédérale et provinciale sa
subvention de condition féminine canada
s'est terminé au bout de trois ans elle
n'était pas renouvelable
normalement durant une campagne
électorale on se dote le mouvement des
femmes d'une plate forme qu'on présente
aux différents partis politiques
et cette année nous n'avons pas pu le
faire par manque de moyens il ya la
table de femmes de montréal hisser la
fédération des femmes du québec depuis
10 ans 17 directrice d'un groupe de
pression en équité à l'emploi le
gouvernement conservateur n'a cessé de
couper les subventions aux groupes de
défense des droits des femmes
plusieurs ont dû mettre la clé sous la
porte il ya des groupes france à la
fédération des femmes du québec qui n'a
plus aucun financement fédéral depuis
des années le forum économique mondial
qui classait le canada il ya dix ans au
septième rang des pays en ce qui
concerne l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes classe maintenant le canada
au 20e rang
ce cours de danse n'est qu'une des cinq
activités aujourd'hui à l'horaire de
pascal déry candidate conservatrice bien
vous laisser ma fille art alors vous
allez pouvoir la connaissent l'ancien
journaliste de tva novice en politique
mère de deux enfants ne vise rien de
moins que la victoire malgré les quinze
mille voix d' avance du candidat npd à
la dernière élection
bonjour le niqab comme un des principaux
thèmes de campagne
ça ne la gêne pas du tout si ça s'est
retrouvé dans l'actualité c'est pas
juste à cause de monsieur harper je
pense que les gens ont réagi de manière
assez virulente je vous dirai au québec
et au canada et c'est long on remarque
ça les touche quand on parle de valeurs
canadiennes d'identité canadienne ça
vient vraiment chercher les gens la
candidate conservatrice défend le bilan
du gouvernement de stephen harper sous
financement des groupes de femmes
enquête sur les femmes autochtones
disparues participation politique des
femmes toutes ces critiques sont selon
elle injustifiée et elle promet de faire
de la cause des femmes une de ses
priorités
si elle est élue pour moi c'est un enjeu
extrêmement important puis tant mieux si
je peux contribuer davantage si je peux
en faire plus pour l'égalité hommes
femmes
c'est sûr que ça fait ça fait partie
c'est intrinsèquement ça fait partie du
d'une femme en général moi je suis pour
ces valeurs là je vais l'aider pas non
plus